bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux le buzz dans la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui on va parler de la manière
qu'on peut avoir de s'initier à la
sociologie par la lecture
et oui la sociologie est une science qui
peut paraître parfois un peu difficile
d'accès notamment quand on voit les
textes des grands fondateurs de la
sociologie etc
ce ne sont pas à des textes qui sont
faciles à lire même pour des sociologues
déjà formés on va dire mais comme la
sociologie et la science de la société
la science des sociétés la science des
relations sociales et bien on peut
trouver de la sociologie partout autour
de nous dans tous nos activités dans nos
goûts etc et dont il est assez facile au
final de s'initier à la sociologie grâce
à des textes qui nous intéresse donc
dans cette vidéo je vous présenter
différentes manières qu'on peut avoir de
s'intéresser à la sociologie ou du monde
d'aborder pour la première fois des
thématiques de sociologie ou même pour
des personnes qui sont plus avancées
mais qui ne sont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
suivi des études de sociologie comment
mieux comprendre certains concepts et
c'est donc c'est parti pour mes conseils
de lecture pour sociologue en herbe
alors le premier réflexe qu'on peut
avoir pour s'initier à la sociologie
c'est tout simplement d'avoir recours à
des contenus de vulgarisation
scientifique
alors eh bien sociaux logos cette chaîne
youtube est une chaîne de vulgarisation
scientifique c'est à dire que je vous
parlais de sujets d'actualité avec un
prisme sociologique ça vous permet
d'appréhender un petit peu la manière
des pensées des sociologues en fait de
comprendre comment se construit une
réflexion sociologique est en quelque
sorte de pouvoir chausser les lunettes
du sociologue mais bien sûr je ne suis
pas du tout la seule sur internet à
faire ce genre de choses donc je vous
mets en garde info plein de
recommandations de podcasts de chaîne
youtube de compte instagram qui vous
permettront d'accéder à du contenu
scientifique de ce sujet plus facilement
un dehors du monde d'internet
on a aussi des contenus et de
vulgarisation sur papier il ya de
nombreux livres qui vous font un peu les
100 fiches pour réviser sa sociaux etc
c'est pas quelque chose que je vous
conseille à moins que vous allez
vraiment
étudiants avec des examens à passer au
final quand on veut s'initier à la
sociologie avec des ouvrages vraiment
classique le mieux je trouve c'est ce
genre de format donc par exemple ici
c'est un ouvrage qui embête synthétise
les thèses principales des sociologues
les plus connus ceux qui ont marqué leur
époque
et tout cela par thème donc voilà je
trouve que c'est ce genre d'ouvragé
plutôt vers lequel on veut se tourner
c'est plus rédiger ses des approches
aussi par thématiques qui sont pas plus
faciles d'accès que de juste apprendre
un peu bêtement les théories sans se
rendre compte de manière concrète que de
quelle manière on va pouvoir les
utiliser et en fait de manière générale
si vous voulez vous initier à la
sociologie la vulgarisation c'est un peu
le premier réflexe qu'on a mais c'est
pas forcément ce qui va être le plus
utile et surtout c'est pas forcément par
là qu'on va vraiment comprendre le
mécanisme de la réflexion sociologique
en effet au niveau lecture je trouve
qu'on veut faire beaucoup mieux que de
se tourner vers du contenu de
vulgarisation est un des plus grands
conseils que je voulais vous donner
c'est de vous tourner vers les essais
attention je ne dis pas que tous les
essais comporte de la sociologie mais il
ya beaucoup d'essais qui sont publiés
chaque année c'est quand même un des
genres littéraires les plus publier les
plus vendus et pour beaucoup il ya des
réflexions sociologiques intéressante à
l'intérieur alors le mieux c'est de se
tourner vers des sujets qui nous
intéressent de base par exemple si je
suis très intéressé par le sujet
d'éducation de sports de politique de
communication et j'en passe les essais
c'est quelque chose qui peut parfois
faire peur mais le but d'un essai c'est
quand même d'être vendus donc on va pas
avoir d écriture très lourde avec
beaucoup de références etc
la plupart du temps ça reste une à un
argumentaire qui est assez fluide qui va
à droite au but qui explose l'argument
un parent de manière claire etc
on n'est pas là dans une optique de
complexification etc
et du coup les essais vraiment c'est
quelque chose que je peux vous
recommander pour commencer à vous
immerger dans une réflexion sociologique
sur un thème de là encore ce que je
voudrais c'est que tout et c'est
évidemment ne sont pas 17 sociologie et
que la part du décès ne sont pas du tout
écrit par des sociologues mais quand
vous achetez un ouvrage qui écrit par
une personne concernée par exemple je
pense à ce que j'ai eu récemment c'est
les incapables de rachid rokki il se
positionne en fait en tant que
professeur de segpa donc dans un collège
difficile avec des enfants qui sont pas
valorisées question dans des classes
spécialisées et il nous parle de son
expérience est en fait à travers son
expérience quand on chausse ses lunettes
du sociologue
on voit toute la complexité des raisons
sociales qui font que ses enfants se
retrouvent dans cette classe là voilà
typiquement ça c'est un genre de
réflexion sociologique
de même je ne saurais que trop vous
conseiller les essais de mona chollet
autant sur les questions du féminisme
avec sorcière ou avec beauté fatale que
sur la question plus politique
puisqu'elle a aussi écrit un essai que
ça va elle rêve de droite qui est très
intéressant également elle a vraiment
fait cette approche de déconstruire avec
des références un peu delà de la pop
culture et c'est des choses qu'on
imagine comme acquise ou du moins on ne
s'intéresse pas forcément la manière
dont elles sont construits est-ce que ça
impacte dans nos vies voilà donc les
essais il y en a énormément je conseille
toujours de vous poser la question en
fait est ce que là je suis en train
grâce à cet essai de mieux comprendre
comment la société a plongé les
individus donc voila vous un conseil à
ces général pour aussi vous faire
comprendre que la sociologie elle est
partout autour de nous d'ailleurs que la
trouvait aussi dans la littérature dans
les bandes dessinées dans les opéras les
pièces de théâtre etc bref il ya de la
sociologie partout autour de nous pour
autant si vous voulez vraiment vous
intéressez à la sociologie et vous
initier à la sociologie pur c'est
vraiment à la science que cela
représente
et bien vous pouvez évidemment lire des
textes universitaires alors les textes
universitaires ça va être très
impressionnant au début donc le muc ne
veut pas aller se lancer tout de suite
dans dubourdieu au dürckheim c'est un
peu les premiers réflexes qu'on peut
avoir de vouloir lire les grands pontes
de la sociologie mais en fait c'est pas
du tout un bon réflexe en fait quand on
est pas forcément déjà sensible à
sociologique on n'a jamais étudié
pendant n'a jamais croisé dans le
parcours universitaire il faut pas je
pense se diriger vers ce genre de
grandes oeuvres parce que ça peut être
très impressionnant et on peut se sentir
vraiment exclu de ce monde qu'est la
sociologie
alors que il ya 2
bruce d'universitaires qui publie des
ouvrages grand public je pense ici
notamment aux ouvrages des pinçon
charlot qui sont donnés un couple de
chercheurs en sciences humaines qui ont
publié une série d'ouvragés qui se
vendent bien et un fait qui sont des
ouvrages vraiment grand public de
réflexion sociologique par exemple ils
ont publié pourquoi les riches sont de
plus en plus riches et les pauvres de
plus en plus pauvres et c'est un ouvrage
qui reprend un raisonnement de sciences
humaines mais en le rendant très
accessible parce que très concret et
pour autant vous avez toute cette
réflexion sociologique qui va vous
pousser à aller plus loin que vos
premières intuitions pour vraiment
saisir la réflexion sociologique qu'il
ya derrière
il ya beaucoup de rage qui ont été
rédigées par des universitaires dans le
but de toucher un large public
je pense notamment récemment à 1% devant
dan à shiva à l'époque il ya aussi
plusieurs universitaires qui ont rédigé
ensemble féminisme pour les 99%
voilà c'est il ya plein de deux ouvrages
universitaires qui sont commis chaque
année a vu le mans cette optique de
sortir des carcans de l'université et
d'aller toucher en dehors du monde
académique mais si vraiment vous voulez
commencer à lire comme un sociologue le
ferai je pense que ce qui peut être
intéressant pour vous c'est de réfléchir
déjà aux sujets qui vous intéressent et
d'aller consulter des rapports de
recherche
les rapports de recherche il ya
plusieurs types évidemment qui sont
disponibles je pense notamment aux
études qui sont à la fois qualitative et
quantitative de par exemple
l'observatoire des inégalités
ça fait assez intéressant en fait pour
essayer de voir votre réaction façade de
la donne est quasiment brut avec quelle
interprétation vous pouvez faire de ces
données par rapport à ce que vous
connaissez donc c'est l'un en fait les
premiers réflexes de sociologues qui
s'installe
et puis ensuite il ya de nombreux
rapports de recherche qui sont commandés
à des sociologues par des institutions
ou par les organismes publics et
également par des ong sur des sujets
très précis par exemple si vous êtes
enseignant ou que vous n'êtes pas dans
le milieu éducatif
eh bien il ya même des rapports qui se
produit en interne par le ministère qui
nous permette d'avoir ce recul un dieu
puisque l'on fait en fait c'est vraiment
des rapports qui suivent une méthode
sociologique qui vous permettent d'avoir
des résultats des conclusions auxquelles
vous pouvez avoir accès assez facilement
et si vous connaissez déjà
ce monde là eh bien ce sera plus simple
pour vous de comprendre et de voir en
fonction de votre real
et voilà si vous êtes dans la tendance
majoritaire ou non ensuite évidemment la
meilleure façon je dirais de s'initier à
la sociologie
c'est en lisant directement des articles
universitaires
quand vous allez lire un article du
master vous avez vraiment lire une
production de chercheurs que d'autres
chercheurs liste également
donc là on est vraiment plus dans la
vulgarisation ou dans la simplification
de l'accès à la sociologie vraiment de
la sociologie pur et dur alors mais
comment faire pour que ces lectures ne
soit pas trop 28 minutes dès le début je
vous conseille vivement d'aller sur
google scholar sur kairn / pers et voilà
ddd site qui en fait regroupe de
nombreuses ressources en sciences
humaines et sociales et de taper des
mots clés qui correspondent à vos sujets
d'intérêt par exemple admettons que je
m'intéresse au sport et plus
particulièrement aux voleurs derby soit
eh bien je vais m roller derby dans la
catégorie sociologique sur les sites en
question et je vais regarder sous les
différentes publications qui existe à ce
sujet et en fonction de ça je peux être
trouvée je ne sais pas une publication
sur les liens entre roller derby et
militantisme féministe aux états unis
d'un sujet qui m'intéresse de base et
donc je pourra lire un article assez
restreint c'est à dire souvent c'est une
dizaine de pages sur un sujet très
précis mais que je connais un petit peu
ce qui fait que la lecture va être plus
simple est que je ne pas forcément être
bloqué par les apports théoriques qui
parfois peuvent être assez
impressionnant quand on prenait pas le
sujet donc voilà pour mes conseils pour
vous initier à la sociologie
encore une fois je vais le répéter mais
la sociologie elle est partout autour de
nous c'est la science de société la
science des relations sociales entre les
individus et entre les groupes sociaux
donc forcément c'est partout autour de
nous c'est dans nos expériences
quotidiennes les plus petits aspects de
nos vies peuvent être soumis à des
réflexions sociologiques
donc n'ayez pas peur de vous lancer sur
des choses très concrètes de pas vouloir
tout de suite s'attaquer aux grandes
pompes de la sociologie c'est pas parce
que vous allez lire dürckheim
aujourd'hui que vous allez comprendre
quelque chose
en fait il vaut mieux parfois partir
vraiment du concret pour s'habituer à
chausser les lunettes de sociologues et
du coup à se mettre à observer le monde
autour de nous en fonction de cette
attitude de cette posture sociologique
qui est de toujours vouloir comprendre
comment la société nous fait agir d'une
manière
d'une autre j'espère que ces quelques
conseils vous aideront à vous lancer
dans des lectures sociologique et puis
en attendant continuez de suivre la
chaîne youtube sociaux logos puisque je
partage du contenu de vulgarisation
scientifique ailleurs si la chaîne vous
plaît n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
peut être un gem à cette vidéo elle a
partagé et à faire vivre sociaux logos
j'étais très heureuse de passer ce
moment avec vous et je vous retrouve
très bientôt sur ces logos
[Musique]